room when you begin your deliberations
on the case after i have instructed you
on the law and the law is what you then
apply to
the facts that you have heard during the
trial once i've instructed you on the
law then we'll have closing closing
arguments closing statements from the
attorneys at that point the order
switches and defense counsel goes first
and the reason for that is as we said
the burden of proof is on the
prosecution in this case and it remains
on the prosecution and so they have the
opportunity for the last word in the
case so they will give the final closing
argument closing arguments also like
opening statements are not to be
considered as evidence but they are very
important the attorneys will stress to
you the the important points that they
have heard during the course of the
trial both from the witnesses and from
the exhibits that have been admitted
into evidence and they will ask you to
take those things into account when you
go to deliberate of course it's up to
you as jurors to decide what you want to
focus on during your deliberations but i
would ask you to be very mindful of the
arguments that are made by both um the
prosecutor and defense counsel in this
case
so that is how and then at that point
you will be taken back to the jury room
for you to begin your deliberations and
you will deliberate as long as it takes
for you to reach a verdict and a verdict
in the in a criminal case has got to be
unanimous so all 12 of the jurors who
are sent back to deliberate it will need
to be you will all need to agree
on the verdict that you have reached as
jurors it's your duty to determine the
facts and to determine those facts from
the evidence and the reasonable
inferences that arise from that evidence
but in so doing you're not to engage in
guesswork or in speculation
you should not be influenced in any
degree by any personal feelings of
sympathy for or prejudice against the
parties for they are entitled to your
fair and your impartial consideration
it's your special duty as jurors to
decide how much credibility you want to
give to a witness's testimony and it's
up to you to decide how to judge that
credibility but some things that you
might want to take into account when
you're judging credibility is that
witnesses opportunity to observe
that witnesses clarity in their
recitation of what they have observed
when they testify before you
you might want to take into account
whether that witness has an interest or
not in the case and in deciding how much
credibility to give to that witnesses
testimony and you also might want to
take into account that witnesses
testimony in conjunction with all the
other testimony that you've heard to see
does this make sense does this fit in
with the other witnesses who have
testified those are just some things you
might want to keep in mind in
determining the credibility of the
witnesses
i'll have further instructions for you
as i said once we have heard all of the
evidence in the case one other thing
that i want to
address with you is that
i'm going to ask that you not have any
communication at all with the attorneys
with the parties in the case
even to ask them where should i go for
lunch or
any uh where's the water fountain
where's closest snack bar
if you have questions of that nature if
you would direct those to the deputy
sheriff he'll be happy to answer those
for you but i'm going to ask you to not
have any communication with council just
to avoid any appearance of impropriety
in case someone else should say i wonder
what's going on there that a juror is
talking to one of the parties or a juror
is talking to one of the attorneys and
i'm also going to
instruct the attorneys to have no
contact with you and also mr hankinson
to have no contact with you as this case
proceeds
all right i believe we are ready for
opening statements and visually if
you're prepared
maybe please report yes
members of the jury
as judge explained to you this part of
the trial is the opening statement it's
a time where
my responsibility is representative of
the commonwealth is to give you a
preview an overview
of what we expect the evidence for the
commonwealth
to be in this case
um
first it's my responsibility to
read you the indictment
one endangerment in the first degree
count one honor about march 13
2020 in jefferson county kentucky the
above name defendant brett hankerson
committed the offense of wanton
endangerment in the first degree
when
under circumstances manifesting extreme
indifference
to human life
he wantedly
shot a gun into an apartment occupied by
c e
initials
count two one endangerment in the first
degree on or about march 13 2020
in jefferson county kentucky the above
named defendant brett hankerson
committed the offense of wanton
endangerment in the first degree
when under circumstances manifesting
extreme indifference to human life
he wantonly shot a gun into an apartment
occupied by c n
count three
endangerment in the first degree on or
about march 13 2020
in jefferson county kentucky the above
name defendant brett hankerson
committed the offense of wanton
endangerment in the first degree
when under circumstances
manifesting extreme indifference to
human life
he wantedly shot a gun into an apartment
occupied by zf
signed by the poor person
as you've heard the indictment is not
evidence
it's the charge that charges returned by
the jefferson county grand jury the
evidence
will be what you hear in this courtroom
from the witness chair
this is not a case
to decide
who is
responsible
for the death of brianna taylor
brianna taylor
should not have died that night
the city of louisville
in a civil matter which i spoke about
yesterday
paid millions of dollars to briana
taylor's family
but the money did not bring her back
nothing will
this is not a case
about the search warrant for brianna
taylor's apartment other than you will
hear
it was a valid search warrant
signed by a judge
this is not a case about the louisville
metro police department
as far as whether or not there
needs to be reform or more support for
officers who put their lives on the line
every day
this is not that case
this is a case about the actions of
brett hankerson
on the night of march
12 march 13
because it started about midnight
2020.
and about as you heard
the circumstances
under which
he acted
you will hear that
he shot into the apartment building
at 3003 springfield drive
and you will hear that his bullets
went through apartment four into
apartment three
and nearly hit cody etherton as he was
walking
down the hallway into the dining room of
his apartment to see what was going on
with the banging
this case
is about cody
and his partner chelsea who was seven
months pregnant at the time
and their five-year-old son who was
sleeping in the bedroom closest to the
front door
when the bullets ripped through the
apartment
and
out
their sliding glass door into the night
there was no search warrant for cody and
chelsea's apartment
exhibit 73 a
73
this is 3003 springfield drive that you
will
hear witnesses testify about
an apartment
for
apartment three
apartment four
patio patio faces the parking lot
apartment three
which you'll see in a minute the door
that leads to apartment three's patio is
at the rear of the building
and this is apartment three's patio
through which one of the bullets
shot by brett hankinson
threw
this
patio all the way through and exited the
patio doors here and into the night
you will hear from some of the officers
who were there that night to serve the
search warrant
you will hear
that as they approached
the apartment floor which was the
apartment of briana taylor
they had the warrant which was signed as
a knock warrant exhibit 5.
this is what you will hear referred to
as the breezeway
the entrance into the building
in this alcove or breezeway there are
doors to four apartments
this is apartment four that you will
hear
a lot of testimony about this is the
entrance into the apartment
of miss taylor this is apartment three
this is cody
and chelsea's apartment
this door right here
this is apartment two
and over out of the photo
which is directly across from
apartment four is apartment one over
here upstairs
are four
more apartments
in the same
design as the first floor
so one two three four
five six seven and eight directly above
four
you will hear
detectives who are assigned to
execute the search warrant
that it was
even though signed as a no dog warrant
decided that it would be served as
knocked and announced
knocked and announced and you'll see a
photo
that shows a large white board
that was
displayed at the briefing
earlier that day
for detectives who would be serving the
warrant
and on the whiteboard you'll see
the words
knock and announce
written above the address 3003
springfield drive apartment 4.
you will hear
the subject of the search warrant
was brianna taylor
who was connected to an individual
named jamarcus glover
designated as a drug trafficking suspect
you will hear
that all of the detectives
who were assigned to serve the search
warrant were experienced detectives
including the defendant
brett hankerson with approximately
20 years
in law enforcement
after the briefing you will hear which
was earlier in the day of march 12th
those assigned to
execute this search warrant met at a
church nearby
springfield drive called saint anthony's
church
met in the parking lot there to
discuss
what the approach would be
on springfield drive
sergeant john mattingly
was designated to be the person the
detective at the door
along with
detective mike nobles
who was carrying a ram you'll see a
photograph of a ram that was ultimately
used to breach the
door other detectives
miles cosgrove
mike campbell
tony james
and sean hoover
detective hankerson
was a k-9 officer
meaning he had a dog
that was trained to
sniff for narcotics
a specifically
trained narcotics
dog
that dog did not
leave the vehicle of the defendant at
any time
the protocol is the dog stays in the car
until the
warrant
until entry is made search is in
progress
if the dog is needed then the dog would
be retrieved from the vehicle that did
not happen here
the dog never left the car
it was approximately 11 45
exhibit 14.
let's go to
19. this uh another photo of the
breezeway and now you can see apartment
one you can see the size of the area
here it's not not large
exit 19.
this photo taken further back
that's the uh
stairs going up to the other four
apartments on the second floor this
being eight
seven six and then five over here
this
the sliding glass doors
of apartment four
and this
uh do the stairs you cannot see the door
to apartment 4 but it's right here
this is the sliding glass doors and you
can see the railing
going around the little patio
this photo was taken
the morning after
so it's like it's daylight
but obviously when this event occurred
it was pitch dark at midnight
you can see
the shadow the shattering
of the window
the glass door
uh in these patio doors
those are the shots that the defendant
made through
these doors
that went all the way through into the
other apartment
apartment three here
which mirrors apartment four
there's a common wall
between the two of them
this
diagram over to your uh right
is a floor plan of apartment three
the door front door being here
dining kitchen bedrooms
and here is the
patio
that leads out into the back
of the building
so the bullets you will hear came
from apartment four which would be down
here this is the common
wall came through the sliding door
here
through the dining room wall all the way
through
out the patio door
of this apartment
there were three bullets
they came through there were five
bullets
actually shot
by the defendant
through the patio doors there were five
three made it through all the way into
apartment
three
one out the patio doors of apartment
three
a fourth one stuck in the stud
of this wall of this common wall
and a fifth one
that went through these doors
didn't make it past the floor
of this uh
not this is uh apartment three didn't
make it through the
apartment four
it was very damaged bullet
it was later determined to have been
fired by detective hankerson's gun it
was found on the floor
in the dining room
of apartment four which would be right
here they mirror each other so it didn't
make it
through the wall but nevertheless was
shot through
the sliding glass door so there were
five total bullets
shot by the defendant through this door
now as
the group of detectives approached
the breezeway
to execute the search warrant
and had lined up
in a
formation with detective mattingly
and detective nobles who's the detective
with the ram
at the front door
um you will hear that detective james
was over in
by this wall
detective
cosgrove was a little bit
further back
detective campbell was the farthest back
lieutenant hoover
also back in this area as was the
defendant
detective hankerson
because there's not room in that little
alcove for seven
men to stand all bunched up so
mattingly and cosgrove mattingly and
nobles
basically at the door
now
once they were in position
you will hear
that a
gentleman
came out
this door which is apartment eight
came out the door
uh to the railing or to the top of the
stairs
and you hear from him his name's aaron
sarpy
who was there to pick up his daughter
from the babysitter
and he was
preparing
he had
come up to this apartment
prior to
the detective's arrival
he had already come to pick up his
daughter
um
and actually his
white sequoia
was parked out in the parking lot
behind
uh it was in a perpendicular
he had pulled up and just parked it
there he didn't pull into a parking spot
to run up and get his daughter
when he came out you will hear
detectives
told him to go back in
prior to
him coming out
they had begun to knock
on the door of apartment four
they had begun to announce police
search warrant
when this gentleman came out
detective hankerson in particular
began to engage verbally with him
telling him to get back in
and continue to engage verbally
with the gentleman
the detectives who were up at the door
couldn't see
mr sarpy they were too far under under
this uh
that landing
but hankerson was back here
he could very well see
uh mr sarpy and began continue to engage
with him to get back inside get back
this
escalated the situation
at that point
finally sarpe did go back in back in the
apartment
at that point
is when the knocking had been going on
for minutes
no response
a decision was made
after
the gentleman went back inside
to go ahead and breach the door
there were three hits
i believe at least three possibly four
with the ram against
the
door handle side
of the wheat
you can't see uh the door here but the
door handle side is on the right of the
door to apartment four
first hit
did not
make the breach
second did not and finally third i
believe it was the third possibly the
fourth that actually
breached
the door handle side at the where the
lock and door on the right side so that
when the door opened
it went right to left
there was no knocking the door off the
hinges
the door as you saw in the earlier
photograph
exhibit
five
which was taken after
uh
the next morning as you see the door is
perfectly still on the hinges
and you can't see but the inside the
lock here hand or doorknob area is where
it was breached
that caused it to open
staying on the hinges opening up
during the time that
and this was
this happened quickly
during the time that the breach was
taking place
detective cosgrove who had been
behind these two were at the door
um
moved up
to cover
detective nobles with the ram
he moved up in this direction to cover
because the defendant
was too busy engaging
with mr starbay upstairs
so carsbro moved up to cover
the guy with the ram because the guy
with the ram isn't doesn't have any
protection but has not got his gun
at the ready
so cosgrove moved up stepped up to cover
which put him in the line of fire
as soon as the door was breached you
will hear
as it
opened up i was pitch dark inside
and a shot came out the door
immediately
and hit
detective mattingly
who was on the left side but it was
attempting to step in
when he was hit
in the leg
and actually the femoral artery
as soon as that shot rang out and hit
detective mattingly
he and detective cosgrove who had
stepped up after detective nobles
breached the door with the ram he spun
out immediately he spun out and was over
here
so he was not
in the doorway
mattingly
and cosgrove who had stepped up and were
in the line of fire and both returned
fire
after mattingly was shot
you will hear
that the defendant henkeson
was not in the line of fire
and go back to um
31a
i think
or 19 i guess 19.
yes
hankerson had been over here engaging
with sarpe
when the shots rang out
when the shot came from inside the
apartment and hit detective mattingly
he ran over this
direction
obviously behind
this
railing and started shooting in a
perpendicular
geometrically
perpendicular to where the shot had come
from inside the apartment
so those in the doorway were shooting
and this is west
this is south here this is south
this is west
east north
north would be this direction so he's
shooting from a south north direction
where the detectives who have been in
the line of fire and returned fire from
the doorway after the door was breached
and they
and they were met with
gunfire
they returned fire west east
obviously in the direction of where the
shooter had shot from
you will hear the shooter was at the end
of the hallway
so he
ran over here into
actually the sidewalk all of his casings
were found in the parking lot
10 shots were fired by the defendant
all 10 casings
were found out here
in the parking lot
none
of course over here all the casings in
this breezeway
that were located by the
crime scene unit
where caseins that have been fired by
the two detectives
in the doorway
cause grovin mattingly
cody atherton and chelsea napper
were asleep
an apartment three
back here in this bedroom
when they heard the banging
the breech
the ram
and cody jumped up you'll hear from him
and
was walking toward the front door to see
what was going on
as he got to this area
a bullet whizzed
close to his head
that he heard
and then saw debris
drywall
dust
where that bullet had come through
bullets
he
ran
he'll tell you he he hit the ground
crawled back
to the bedroom
chelsea napper will testify
she woke up
from sleep and she is not
a she's a very heavy sleeper but woke up
immediately
from these bangings
and froze
froze
she couldn't move she couldn't
yet knowing her five-year-old son was
asleep in this bedroom
so cody ran back
crawled back to the bedroom
they then were able to go get the child
as cody came back out
the firing had stopped
the gunfire stopped he came back out and
then noticed the shattered glass
of their patio door and all the glass
you'll see laying on the carpet
and you'll also hear there was a bullet
one of the bullets
likely that hit
above that door the doorway you'll see
photo and the bullet bounced back and
landed one of them landed in the carpet
there
but one went all the way did shatter the
glass
they called 911
it was cold that night
so their door which had been shattered
cold air was pouring in
you will hear that
the radio
the defendant got on the radio
after the shooting and called
for patrol
you'll hear radio clips of him calling
patrol car after patrol car came to the
scene some of the patrol carl
cars you will hear
some of the patrol officers went to the
back of the building
and cody etherton was
in some danger because at that point
no one knew
that he was actually in a separate
apartment
so there were guns pointed at him
as he stood
in the shattered
and put his hands out this uh shattered
glass
and saw guns pointed at him from these
patrol that came
so that's part of the circumstances
that were created
by the defendant in apartment three
that's part of the circumstances that
you will hear about
you will hear that the defendant gave a
statement and you will hear the
statement
to the public integrity unit which was
called to investigate the scene
to
process the scene
to interview all the detectives
you will hear that the defendant claimed
that he saw
into the doorway
the front door
and he claimed that he saw
a shooter in there with an ar rifle
in a combat position
and that
that he actually was standing here that
he could see in
and that he returned fire when he saw
that
shooter with an ar rifle uh start
shooting
you will learn that there was no ar
rifle in apartment four
there was one pistol
a glock 43 x nine millimeter
which had been used by the shooter
inside and it was found under a bed
in
the front bedroom
under a bed in the front
not the back bedroom which was where
miss taylor
and
her boyfriend had been
but under
a bed in the
front bedroom which window faces the
parking lot it's
next to these doors
down just a little bit
and one gun
one pistol nine millimeter
and there was
a casing that matched that nine
millimeter
found in the hallway
down the hallway
and there was one bullet
which matched
the shooter in the apartment's gun the
nine millimeter found under the bed one
bullet
was later found out in the breezeway
where detective mattingly had been shot
the bullet went through his leg and was
found in the breezeway and was later
identified as having been fired from the
gun found under the bed in the apartment
the nine millimeter
there was never any ar
long rifle
you will hear from
officers who were there you will hear
from the
swat team that came
shortly after to clear the apartment
the swat team came to clear
the apartment
four
and um you will see some
body worn cameras
that the swat team had
you will see
that the defendant you'll see him in
some of these body cameras that the swat
team was wearing
because at
after the shooting the officers
are
assisting mattingly to get
to the hospital he was bleeding out
but the defendant was
still
covering or pointing his gun at this
apartment there were patrol officers
also doing that
however once the swat team arrived
the other officers
did not attempt to go
into the apartment
the defendant did
he came to the door and attempted to go
in to the apartment while the swat team
was trying to clear
you will hear from
firearms examiners
who tested the
casings and the bullets retrieved at the
scene to the gun belonging to hankerson
and as i said they determined that all
10 of the casings found in the parking
lot were fired from his it's a glock
model 22
40 caliber
service weapon
all 10 casings
in that parking lot area were fired from
his gun you will hear from
firearms instructors
at louisville metro
who will describe to you the training
that goes
takes place uh
with
officers at louisville metro
you will hear from
an officer or a major who
has knowledge of and will tell you about
not only the firearms training but the
history of the training that this
defendant
has had in his career as a law
enforcement officer
the major will
describe
some of these specific training courses
but you will actually have
an entire transcript
of the trainings that he has had since
being a law enforcement officer going
all the way back to 1999
i believe when he went to basic training
you will hear from some of the witnesses
who were at the hospital following the
shooting
where john mattingly had been taken
and the defendant went to the hospital
so you will hear from some witnesses who
engaged with him at the hospital
you will
see photographs
that were taken by the crime scene unit
inside apartment 4
as they process the scene
the body of miss taylor
will be in one of the photos at the end
of the hallway
at the very end of the hallway
directly
inside this door looking straight ahead
is the hallway
and at the very end of the hallway
on the floor
is the body of miss taylor
it
by return fire
of those detectives in the doorway
who were returning
fire after mattingly was shocked
so i ask you to pay close attention
to the testimony
and keep in mind
what are the circumstances here under
which this defendant acted what are the
circumstances which
exhibited
extreme indifference to human life
starting with
the gentleman upstairs
what was his reaction to that how did
that impact
everything that
followed
the circumstances of this crowded
apartment building
many many people in this building
starting with mr sarpeh
and ending
with cody
chelsea
and five-year-old satan
thank you
mr matthews do you wish to present an
opening statement your honor thank you
hey please support yes israeli mr thank
you ladies and gentlemen
first of all we finally have made it
we've been through this jury selection
process now it's time to get to work
you all 15 have been selected from a
large group and we've determined that
you're the ones that are most suitable
and qualified to sit on this jury and
decide the issues at hand
as judge smith indicated to you what i
say in my opening statement and what ms
whaley just told you is not evidence
a lot of people refer to opening
statements as opening arguments in fact
that's a total misnomer it's an opening
statement an argument is made at the
close of the case after you've heard all
the evidence we try to sum up what we
think it has shown the opening statement
as the judge indicated is our
opportunity
to kind of provide you with a road map
of where we expect the evidence to go
we've just spent
i'm not sure how long listening to ms
whaley
explain what she thinks the evidence
will show i could go on for another two
hours
filling in gaps that she did not
present or or
providing you with further information
i'm not going to do that
because the evidence that you're going
to hear in this case is going to come
from that witness stand and from any any
exhibits that are presented to you you
alone are going to decide
what this case is all about
um
but just to begin with ladies and
gentlemen
the the charge here is wanton
endangerment in the first degree times
three three counts as ms whaley just
explained to you
the commonwealth's position is and you
just heard ms whaley tell you that brett
hankerson was present at that scene and
about everything he did was wrong and it
amounts to wanting endangerment it adds
up to want endangerment
the
the
path that we are choosing is well first
of all
the the evidence is going to
not be disputed too much by us
with what ms whaley just said there's a
lot more to fill in the gaps but
basically there's not going to be any
dispute about the evidence this is not a
case of hey they've got the wrong guy
sitting in here or somebody else did it
brett hankerson is the one that's
charged he's the one that fired the
shots that are the subject of this this
case so that's not an issue the issue is
what was the reasoning behind his firing
those shots ms whaley indicates that his
his interaction with mr sarpeh up on the
balcony that was up there
was there's something wrong with that
she indicates that he couldn't have seen
what was in what was going on inside the
door once it was breached
she doesn't know that and you're going
to hear ladies and gentlemen i assume
from the witness from the other there
were seven total
um
lmpd officers out there brianna taylor's
apartment to serve that search warrant
and you're going to hear
from at least probably five of them i
think um i'm sure one is not going to
testify you're going to also hear from
brett hankinson when it's his turn but
through hearing from those offices
you're going to discover that this scene
was total chaos
and just
unbelievable chaotic situation and
nobody
they all have about the same
recollection of what occurred but
everybody's got something different and
people don't know where each other were
so
ms whaley telling you definitively that
mr hankinson was out of the picture and
couldn't see in that hallway when that
door was breached is not accurate and
you're going to be determining the facts
but brett hankerson's going to tell you
that when that door was breached he had
a straight shot in that hallway he saw
the muzzle flash from the gun that was
fired at the officers as they breached
that door
his perception of it was that it was an
ar-15 rifle
ms whaley said there was no ar-15 rifle
in that apartment
um
there i don't think there's going to be
any evidence to establish one way or
another whether there was
the evidence is going to be that once
that shot was fired and and the officers
returned fire
the search warrant that they were there
to execute to begin with was never
served
the shots were fired brianna taylor was
killed
swat was called in to take over the
scene after brett hankerson successfully
assisted in calling the the shooter out
of the apartment without any harm coming
to him
once swat arrived on the scene they took
over and they turned it over to the
public integrity unit which conducted
the investigation of the shooting that
nobody ended up serving the search
warrant that the police were originally
there to serve so there we don't know
whether there was any contraband in that
apartment um
and and what kind of contraband there
may have been
i believe the evidence will show
that sometime
later on march the 13th and the day
after this all occurred
the family was granted access to the
apartment
unaccompanied
and there's no nobody knows what what
could have happened within that
apartment but you'll you're going to
hear
from officer from fbi agent zigler about
some shell casings that he examined
besides the shell casings recovered from
what the police fired and i believe that
there's there could be some doubt about
what whether or not off detective
hankerson could have in fact seen an ar
rifle
in any event ladies and gentlemen be
that as it may no matter what the
evidence shows
detective hankinson returned fire
and and you have to understand i think
everybody was out there is going to tell
you that this entire incident after the
knocking and announcing it occurred
after the breach had occurred the entire
incident lasted from anywhere from five
to fifteen seconds nobody had a
stopwatch and timed it exactly but it
was all instantly
officer mattingly was shot he returned
fire
officer cosgrove was next to him he
returned fire
um
and brett hankerson slept around the
side as you saw on the photograph that
was up there and he returned fire in the
direction of where he had seen
the the original shot come from within
the apartment he was attempting to
defend and save the lives of his brother
officers who he thought were still
caught in what they call the fatal
funnel in that doorway and what what he
saw was he was responding number one to
the original shot and he also will tell
you that he saw muzzle flashes which
probably as it turns out were returned
fire from
um from cosgrove and mattingly but he
was firing in in the direction of that
as he was taught to do you're talk to
shoot just until the threat is stopped
um you're obligated under the
the operating procedures of the lmpd to
defend
yourself your brother sister officers
and and citizens and that's exactly what
brett hankerson was doing in this
situation i think after you've heard all
the evidence
rather than go down the path that ms
whaley wants you to go down and find him
guilty of wanting endangerment three
times over you're going to find that to
go down the path that we suggest you go
down and find that he was justified his
actions were reasonable
and justified given that the chaotic
situation he was in
and we're going to we're going to hear
from a number of officers i believe who
are firearms instructors and range
instructors who are going to say that
there are certain rules that you have to
follow
when you're discharging a weapon whether
you're a police officer or just a
citizen who's out shooting there are
certain basic rules we aren't going to
dispute any of that
but
the officers go through training and
i'll tell you one thing that none of
these people are going to say is that
they're they are trained under
circumstances such as existed on march
13th 2020
in briana taylor's apartment and again
as i said during war dyer this case is
not about the death of brianna taylor
but in fact that's what it is it's
totally about that in a sense that
that's what started this whole situation
we're concerned with the three occupants
of apartment 3
who were not injured um and
were not even on the radar as far as
brett hankisson was concerned
ms whaley told you about the briefing
that that the officers attended before
they went out to springfield and i'm
going to fill in i don't want to get
into
great minutiae detail but there were two
separate briefings there was a number of
search warrants that were going to be
served that night was the intention swat
was
part of one briefing and the officers
who went
out to springfield were part of a
different briefing
nobody in the briefing
that was that was held with reference to
springfield ever mentioned
apartment 3 or the layout of the
building these officers went in there
had no idea what they were getting into
and part of the reason for that was
that the other search warrants that were
going to be were going to be served that
night were for
places that were
well known to the police and well known
to contain guns and drugs
brianna taylor was kind of a peripheral
part of this whole deal
and but she was tied into it and they
had a valid search warrant to go there
but
it was determined it was issued as ms
whaley said as a no knock warrant that
means they can just go up and ram that
door and go inside but somewhere along
the line that night it was determined
that brianna taylor um was was not a
threat to anybody they didn't think she
was a threat to anybody it was it was
thought that she was living alone she
didn't have kids she didn't have animals
um
nobody thought there would be any danger
there and so i think that somebody
dropped the ball and there wasn't as
much preparation done in the search of
her place which is what
led up to
the shooting of john mattingly and
ultimately to detective hankinson firing
his rounds through her apartment that
went into apartment three
all of that happened instantaneously all
together and i think ladies and
gentlemen after you've heard all the
evidence you're going to determine that
fred hankinson was justified in what he
did and everything he did on that scene
out there
before during and after the shooting
occurred
was logical was reasonable was justified
and made total sense
so i would ask you to keep an open and
clear close and pay close attention to
this case into the evidence because
that's what's going to come from that
witness chair and from the exhibits not
what i've just said or not what ms
whaley said thank you
all right ladies and gentlemen why don't
we take about a 15-minute break and then
we'll get started with the first witness
please remember the separation
admonition to not discuss the case with
anyone or allow anyone to discuss the
case with you don't form opinions as
you've not heard any of the um evidence
yet we'll come back at eleven o'clock
thank you
all rise reporting great
face down
anything to report from the break ladies
and gentlemen
all right good
miss whaley are you ready to call your
first witness
cody etherton
so
you could take a seat please
and if you'll raise your right hand
he's almost for the testimony you're
about to give will be the truth the
whole truth nothing but the truth so
help you god yes your honor thank you
you put your hand down
would you state the name for your for
the jury and speak up so we can hear you
my name is cody etherton
how old are you cody i am 29.
and do you live in louisville
yes
um
are you did you grow up in louisville
yes
and you go to high school here yes which
high school fair deal
okay and make remember to speak up
um
where do you work
cody
uh currently working for
a guy named rob hendrickson it's a
remodeling business
and
who do you
live with
currently i live with chelsea napper
and uh
my son bryson and her son
zayden
and you all how long have you and
chelsea been together
um six
years yeah
and so
when you all
met
uh
her son satan she had her son zayden or
had not i guess she had
um
yes
yes she
uh
we're both in recovery so she was in the
process of
getting him back
and uh we both have four over four years
sober
so she was getting her stuff together
getting her life together
so that she could be a stable stable
mother for him i see yes so you all
are both in recovery now yes ma'am and
how long have you been sober i have been
sober since december 23 of 2017.
so congratulations over over four years
congratulations thank you
um
so
you all been together six years
and
you all have a son now
yes ma'am and what's his name
his name is bryson
etherton
on and how old is bryson now
bryson is
uh 20 months
okay
so i'm gonna take you back now to march
of 2020
uh was chelsea pregnant with bryson at
that time
yes ma'am i believe that she was around
seven months pregnant with my son
and where did you all live in march of
2020
we lived on
we lived in saint anthony gardens
apartments uh
3003 springfield drive apartment three
apartment three and how long had you
lived there
at
march of 2020 how long had you all been
there i think at that day we was around
going on like
i believe
two years
going on about two years
did you know
the neighbors
in the building there
at 3003
no i did not i've seen them a few
times um
didn't really didn't really know
didn't even know their names when i say
neighbors you all had quite a few
apartments in the building yes so
you all were apartment three
and
did you know
the
people who lived in apartment four
as you come out
your door be to your left
no i did not i've seen them coming in
and out we said hi
that was it like i never knew their
names
and who did you think lived there as far
as male female how many people
i was under the impression that about
three people live there
which would be
uh two females and a male
okay
now what about apartment
to your right as you come out your door
apartment two did you know those folks
um
i don't remember her name but i did talk
to her she was a sweet older lady
she was very
friendly
we did have
quite a few conversations they was real
short
but like i said i
i don't even remember her name be honest
okay
any
any of the other neighbors that you knew
um
no
so you all
busy back at that time you all had
active lives
yes ma'am um i i worked a lot
sometimes
10 hours
sometimes even more days um
work weekends too
and like i said we was
you know we was
in bed ten o'clock
up seven o'clock next morning off to
work you know at work by eight every
single day monday through friday
okay uh i'm going to show you a
exhibit
a floor plan of your apartment
right
so
what do i think
so
deputy ballinger he indicated he was
next
door it's not oh
it's not responding okay
so
so
well i think we're going to go the
old-fashioned way
and use the poster
oh here's deputy
there you go
okay um cody if you would
can we get it on both screen
is it on your screen yes ma'am okay
he has it on his screen here
if you could um
look at the floor plan on the screen
and point out where
your you and chelsea slept where's your
bedroom
i'm not sure
i think you may have to use the pointer
to the screen behind you the laser
pointer yeah okay
so me and chelsea slept in this back
bedroom here
okay and then where did zayden sleep
zayden slept along this wall
and uh in his bedroom
is that where his bed was
yes it was actually
long ways against this wall
okay
and just go ahead and point out the
front door to the apartment
this here was the front door
okay
now um
on the night of march 12th
uh
what time did you all go to bed
i believe we was we was definitely in
bed by 10 10 30.
and
zayden was in bed
yes ma'am
so
what happened after that after you went
to bed
um
so we were sleeping and um
i got woke to what
um
so it was like a loud a loud boom
and uh
i jumped on my feet
and she she jumped out of the bed as
well
and um
you know i
kind of speak you know sped walk down
the hallway
uh the hallway here
and uh in my mind i was thinking that
for some reason i just thought that
somebody was trying to come into our
apartment
so my instinct was to
go to the front door
of course to protect protect my family
so
as i made it down the end of the hall
and i came out into the
living room dining room area
our kitchen table was here
on this wall in the dining room and
right when i came out into the open
um
just debris started going past my head
my face
which
i pretty much knew because i mean i
heard the shots
pretty much knew that it was uh gunfire
coming through the wall
because that's what i do for a living is
remodeling so when the drywall started
hitting in the face like i already knew
uh so i hit the floor
and um rolled back rolled back into the
hallway went back into the bedroom made
her get on the ground
um
there was probably maybe a 30 second
pause
everything got silent after the shots
like
i don't even remember how many shots i
heard because it was just so chaotic
i remember hearing them but i couldn't
tell you how many i heard like it was
all at once to me
and
after the silent
i i believe that i heard
um
lmpd get get down on the ground get down
on the ground or or
somewhere along those lines i heard
something like i heard lmpd announce
themselves outside like that's all i
remember and i remember having like a
relief i was like okay
the police are out there
you know it kind of released my mind
because like i didn't know what to think
at the time like i didn't know if people
were outside in the breezeway fighting
shooting at each other i didn't know if
he was getting robbed like i just didn't
know what was going on
and uh
so after i heard the the
lmpd
yelling outside
um i kind of waited pause made her stay
still
and then everything got silent again
and that's when
i came back out into the hallway out
into the dining room and
i looked through the peephole
and i didn't see anything at all the
people point out where that is
that was right here in the front door
and i didn't see
i didn't see anything when i looked
through the peephole so
for some reason i opened the door and i
walked out and i had no shirt on red
basketball shorts um
i don't think i had
flip flops or anything i think i was
barefooted
and i walked all the way out to the
breezeway and i looked left and i seen
uh the neighbor's door busted wide open
but it was pitch black inside and then
um that's when i would be apartment four
to your left
yes ma'am okay and uh that that's when i
heard
um did you look in the door
yeah i looked in there but it was it was
black black as night and i couldn't
couldn't really see anything couldn't
make up of anything um
and i remember anybody
no didn't see anything i could see
like flashing lights around the corner
of the building
uh but straight ahead there was there
was nobody there was nothing
um hey what'd you do
and i
after i looked down the hall or into her
bedroom
or apartment
i
i heard
i heard somebody saying
i believe that was uh breathe baby
breathe
breathe
i think it was breathe baby breathe
that's what that's what i remember
hearing uh
and that's when i knew i was like this
is serious like um so i kept walking out
towards the edge of the steps at the end
of the breezeway just to look out into
the parking lot to see what was going on
that's when some officers seen me and
they
ordered me to get back into the
apartment immediately
so i did i turned around went went back
inside shut the door locked it
um
and then i remember hearing from our
back
patio screen door i remember hearing all
the glass just shuttering falling
so i walked to it
and uh i pulled the sliding blinds open
just to look at it
and when i did there was
not sure if it was police or swat or
what but they were
i remember seeing a dog i remember
seeing a dog to my left a canine
and then i seen um i believe i've seen
i know i had flashlights on me but i
believe i've seen red dots um
and
you know out the back of the patio out
the back of the patio and they they seen
me and i heard them say red uh white
male
red basketball shorts no shirt round
back i remember hearing it you could
hear it on the radio
um
and they instructed me to put my hands
out the door through the falling glass
they said put your hands out the window
that's what they said
and i was like all right to me that was
not a good idea for one because there's
falling glass
so i immediately shut the blinds back
and jarred it back down into the hallway
um
and i remember thinking i was like
they're getting ready to stick this dog
in here
and and i have a dog i had a dog as well
and i remember thinking like if his dog
gets in here
you know he's going to harm us
did they have guns
yes
pointed at where
uh they were pointed all towards the
door like i believe that i even had uh
you know i remember seeing red dots
going across like
tours like i was at the doorway
and uh i remember i remember seeing red
dots like crossing me
you know where i was standing
and uh they definitely had lights shined
on me or and told you put your hands out
the broken glass yes ma'am and but you
didn't no
i did not um
i immediately ran back down into the
hallway
and we had to point out where you ran
back i ran back down into the hallway
and chelsea was standing right here
um she may have been sitting down right
there
but i remember her she got up
and stood up and i said get 9-1-1
or she might have even had 9-1-1 on the
phone
and i made her call him back
i believe that's what happened she was
already on the phone when i was one and
she hung up and i said
call them back and tell them
that whatever's going on this this is
the wrong apartment
like because i already i could put two
and two together like i was like
you know of course i seen the busted
door
so i knew that i i immediately put two
and two together i was like they think
my back door is her back door
that's what i thought
and um which to me
is uh
just very unorganized like they you know
to me
a professional you know
a well-trained officer
they should have had the floor plans
they should have had the blueprints like
they didn't even know whose backdoor
that was they didn't even know who lived
there so to me
that kind of upset me
it was just reckless to me
and so
she got him back on the phone and i told
them to tell them that this is not the
same apartment whatever's going on
uh they're
holding me at gunpoint telling me to put
my hands out the window blah blah blah
and then they said uh it's fine sit
still we'll get uh they they said
they'll sort it out or whatever and
we'll send the officer over there
um
so
she hung up the phone
and
um
we
i think we sat there honestly
um she hung up the phone
and at one point not too long after that
i ended up going back to the door to the
front door
and looking through the peephole again
and uh
and that's when i watched them
um talk the guy talk talk a male
uh with his hands up walking backwards
uh towards the end of the breezeway they
was instructing him
um out of out of the uh apartment four
uh made him walk backwards with his
hands up and then i watched him uh i
literally watched him get down on his
knees at the end of the steps and
uh watched him arrested
through the p-puddle through the
peephole yes ma'am
and so after that um
we sat there an hour hour and a half
maybe two hours before anybody even came
in and checked on us
it was cold that it was cold that night
our door our
like i said our patio
our patio screen door a glass door
sliding door was shattered
we was freezing
luckily
her son at the time
did not wake up
um
he did wake up
um
later on
early the next morning
um
and
and i'm i remember i think she told him
that a storm came or something
but we sat there uh for a while
and then in my mind i was like well
i'm gonna i'm gonna try to go back to
sleep and get some rest i'm gonna go to
work like for some reason i was gonna go
to work that next morning
they wouldn't let me out of the
apartment to even go to work
because i tried and they said no you
cannot leave the apartment this is a
crime scene
come into the apartment and vote take
photographs
and collect
uh
bullets
yes ma'am
now if you would look at the photograph
on the screen
94
and take your pointer and explain what
that shows
so this shot here um i believe is the
one that i was interested actually
inches away from hitting me
uh because i was i was eye level with
this with this hole here
and like i said i was literally standing
in front of the table at the end of the
hallway when this happened and then
bullets came through
the wall
um
like in one more like i i literally like
one or two more inches and i would have
been shot
uh which kind of upsets me because i
think about it all the time and i'm like
my son would have never even got to meet
me i would never even got to meet my son
um
i mean any of them bullets could have
went anywhere you know there's another
bullet in the clock
or bullet hole yes there's another one
here and then there's one down here
above the chair rail going to um
next photo
there and then the other bullet hole in
the clock
yes
go on the 90s
then is that the third bullet hole
yes ma'am this this one i believe uh
bounced up on the table
hey
um
this next photo
again of the dining room table
uh and i think the next one 98.
is that the bullet that landed on
came through that uh
drywall there the chair rail i guess and
hit the
table yes ma'am
now this photo exhibit 100 tell us what
this is showing so this here is the end
of the hallway
this is where her son zayden was
sleeping along this wall this is where
his bed is other side of the wall is on
the other side of the wall so you know
i literally i literally measured it it
was like seven more feet to the right
and that bullet would have entered his
room
and you came down that hall
when you heard the banging yes i came
down the hall right i was standing right
here
when i dropped when i when i dropped to
the ground
after the debris came
through the wall yes ma'am
there uh
exhibit 101 here what does this show
this this is showing our patio sliding
glass door
now uh
and up here is another bullet
i believe this bullet
bounced back out off the brick on the
other side and landed somewhere on the
ground here we'll go on to the next
photo
102.
is this your
patio door yes now
and at the bottom of that photo is that
the shattered glass we see on the carpet
yes now
now this photo is a close-up of what you
were explaining
the bullet at the top there
bullet defect
so it didn't actually go through the
wall
it was found on the carpet below
we'll see in the next photo i think
uh
but that can you go back to 100
well three
the blind there the the hole in the
blind
that's a bullet hole that the one that
actually went through and shattered
yes man i believe so
now this is a close-up of that some of
that shattered glass
right below the
sliding door and that's a bullet there
you want to point that out
now
when did you all actually
were you actually able to leave the
apartment and how did that happen
that next day which would have been the
march 13th
i'm not sure the exact time uh it was
hours
it was so it was several hours that we
remained in the apartment
like i said i don't recall the exact
time like that we was able to leave
and when you left what how did you
how did you leave did you go out the
front door
um
they told us we could go around back go
out back
um
through the broken door
yeah through the broken door
uh they told us we could go around back
and
and
um
leave that way but like i said like our
vehicles were right in the middle
uh so there was there was no leaving um
chelsea at one point
went to look for maintenance to the at
the office
with her son
to see about somebody at least boarding
it up or replacing the door
because like i said it was cold
um
i'm like i'm not sure i'm not sure how
many hours we remained in there but it
was it was several hours at some point
you got permission that you could go out
the front
yes uh at one point they did uh tell us
that it was clear and it was okay to
exit out the front
and i remember uh walking out there and
looking at my my work truck and i
remember seeing blood
on the side of my work truck and i was
like and i i knew what it was
i knew what it was from
um
but
i i don't even think we left that day
after that like uh
we was still trying to put it all
together in our heads like really what
just happened
now these photos that you've been
describing
are they a fair and accurate
representation of how your apartment
looked that night
yes they are
oh there are commonwealth removed to
admit
94
108
94 and then 95 96
did you show all of those
94 through
105.
this is 105 here the last photo that we
saw
all right i thought we maybe i'm wrong i
thought we skipped from 94 and then the
next exhibit that you showed was 100.
so 95 okay
any objection
judge i don't have any objection i'm not
sure that 94 through 105 were all shown
but um
they're all about the same
94 people
so
we could go back through them
why don't we why don't we just go
through them quickly okay
this is 94.
uh
look at the photo
you talked about uh the claw
the table
95
close close-up of the clock
96
when the defect in the wall
97
table and
can you see the bullet on the table
there
okay thank you
um 98
99 to point out the close-up of the
bullet
is 100
the hallway that you came down
number one
a
further back photo of the sliding doors
with the blinds
sliding door
103
the close-up of the blinds showing the
two defects
bullet defects
104
so in the glass that it shattered out of
the sliding door
and 105 the close-up of the bullet
all right those will all be admitted
into evidence
and
i have no further questions thank you
cody
all right cross-examination
thank you
mr etherton
on march the 20th
remark i'm sorry march the 12th 2020 you
indicated you went to bed about 10 30
correct
yes had you been outside before you went
to bed
i don't know if i took the trash out or
not but that would be the only reason or
to go to my truck do you remember
observing any unusual activity in the
parking lot
no i do not okay
um so you went to bed you and chelsea
were asleep zayden was asleep
and the next thing you know you were
awakened to allowed i think you said a
boom correct
yes do you know what that boom was
um
yeah i figured i figured it out after
the fact
it was what i believe what is called a
ram
it was not gunshots correct no had you
heard any voices before you heard the
loud boom
no i was asleep
when you heard the boom that woke you up
correct
i believe that um i was
i was i believe i was i believe i was
working uh woke up on either this i'm
not even sure how many times that door
was rammed if it was rammed two or three
times but i believe
like i started coming out of my sleep on
the first boom and then it was like boom
again and then that's when i was i
believe that's what i i remember
um it was
when you were awakened and hearing the
boom were you hearing any voices
no not at all
is that because there weren't any voices
or because you just had been awakened
and weren't conscious of it
no i heard no voice
until after the gunfire uh entered
through our wall
okay so you had heard anything up to
that point correct
what what was the gun fire how did that
happen
um like i said
i don't even like
i don't know if it's something that my
brain just shut down on but like i don't
even
actually remembering uh hearing like uh
each and every
gunfire that was let off because like
after the fact i've
you know it was all over the news and
stuff i was like wow that many shots
were made but i don't even remember
hearing that many shots like
we want to know what you remember from
that night not what you heard on the
news okay yeah were these gunshots that
you heard
how long did that last if you can
estimate
um
to me i mean
it was just like
i know i know i remember hearing like
two of them
i know that for a fact like i just i
don't know like like i said i can't even
remember hearing them hearing every
single gunshot like i just
remember hitting the floor
being scared
and rolling back into the hallway
were the gunshots something that seemed
to have happened all at
the same instant
um like i said i remember hearing a
couple of them
but
yeah i mean it seems like it just did
just
okay and you and
chelsea and zayden were not hurt or not
injured right or struck by anything
no i was struck by
drywall debris
but no
but you were able to get back to the
back bedroom
yes
and
during the course of going to the back
bedroom did you hear any voices from
outside
um yes like i said before um when i ran
back into the back bedroom
and told her to get down on the ground
because i didn't know what was going on
um
that's when i believe i remember hearing
lmpd
uh get on the ground or something like
that
and then everything got silent was that
directed toward you or somewhere else
i
i could hear it outside so it was yeah
it was outside i mean they they weren't
talking to you as far as you know not at
that point no okay
um did you you said at one point you
went peeked out the peephole correct yes
where was that in this sequence of
events
that was
um
i looked at the people two different
times
the first time
was
after everything got quiet again after i
heard lmpd get down on the ground
everything got quiet again that was
after the shots correct that first time
yes
and when you looked at the peephole what
if anything did you see
see nothing
no police
i seen our christmas tree that we had
set out to um it was was going to take
it to the dumpster
we had an old christmas tree we bought a
new one so it was scattered all it was
one of those fake trees and it was
scattered all over the place i remember
seeing that through the people okay
was your range of vision kind of narrow
through that peephole or could you see
that much of that breezeway
no i could see you know i could see the
hole i could see all i could see my
truck all the way on the parking lot
front of my truck okay you didn't see
um any police officers or anybody around
is that correct
not at that moment could you tell that
the door to apartment 4 had been
been
breached or opened
um
i believe i did see it
um i seen part of the door like you
could see this side of the door jamb
um
but that wasn't like that didn't um
that that didn't go through my mind like
i don't remember telling myself like her
door is open at that point it wasn't it
wasn't until i actually opened the door
and took a step out that i was like
i seen her door busted wide open okay
well that's what i'm trying to figure
out you you stepped out into that little
breezeway correct or vestibule whatever
we're going to call it yes and there's
nobody around no not at that moment
nobody said anything to you at that
moment there's no gunfire
not at that moment
so
what'd you do close the door and go back
inside no like i said before um
i started hearing
a male's voice saying breathe baby
breathe
and i could see flashing lights around
the corner of the complex and that's
when i
walked out further to the edge of the
breezeway
and then that's when um
officers or i don't know if it was swat
officers i don't know who even said it
but they said get that f back into the
apartment
and i immediately turned back and went
into the apartment
because i
where were those officers who said that
i don't even remember i just heard it
like i don't even remember where they
were standing i believe they was off i
know it was off to the right but i mean
i don't
know exactly what car or where they were
standing by
do you know where the breathed baby
breathe was coming from
yeah i do now yes well i mean back then
did you know
i mean i like to think of myself as a
pretty smart guy i was figuring it out
as i was experiencing it well you would
use the term it was very chaotic right
absolutely so it's very understandable
why you can't
recall precisely what what happened
um
when you say it was very chaotic what do
you mean by that
i'm talking about the
yeah the whole thing was chaotic from
the time that i got woke up to a loud
boom gun fire coming through my wall
nearly killing me could have struck my
girlfriend it was chaos it was chaos
can you estimate how long that lasted
was it minutes seconds
i mean yeah i'm sure it was seconds it's
gunfire um
you at some point then you said you were
stuck in the apartment for
some period of time
yes and i think you said it was an hour
hour and a half two hours you don't
really know right
yeah it was around an hour and a half
two hours have you you never ventured
out again
no no i never stepped foot back out of
the apartment until it was all over okay
was the the incident with putting your
hands out though or being told to put
your hands out
the shattered sliding glass door was
that
part of the initial chaotic part of it
that you've talked about yes that was
after i came back in uh the uh the first
time i looked at the peephole and then
when i when they told me to come back in
i went back in
and then that's when i went to
check our sliding glass door out and
then that's when that happened as when i
pulled the blinds back they were
standing they were all standing out back
could you were those uniformed police
officers could you tell
i have no idea it was black all i seen
was lights and i mean i remember
i remember seeing a dog
to my
left
okay and so then you went back in i
think you described how chelsea was on
the phone with 9-1-1
and hung up and you told her to call
back again and tell them hey you got the
wrong guy right
this is the wrong apartment yeah we're
different
okay
at some point
do you remember
well at some point a somebody from lmpd
contacted you correct
yes when was that
um like i said it was probably about an
hour
and a half two hours do you remember who
that was
i don't know him by his name he was a
male officer
um
i don't know him by his name
he came in
we signed a paper
for them to
collect evidence
does the name sergeant luke fan mean
anything to you that's it okay
um was he with somebody else or by
himself
do you remember
there was another person
and they had you signed a piece of paper
that allowed them to come in and
search your apartment basically
yes is that right okay
um do you remember telling him that you
heard not heard officers knocking and
announcing
no i never heard officer knocker
announcing you didn't tell sergeant luke
fan that
absolutely not okay
you recall telling him that you went to
the door and realized they weren't
knocking for you
they weren't knocking on your door
i didn't speak to that officer at all
like i didn't tell him about anything it
was okay
i remember my girlfriend asking him
uh was this lmpd that did this and
one of them responded
um
i think they said we're
we're not sure or
something along those lines
okay
you don't know
brett hankinson is that correct no you
recall seeing him at all that night
no i didn't
see any officers besides the ones that
came in to collect the evidence like
actual face to face you know this that
would have been after the after the
event correct
uh when they collect the evidence yes
yes was that the next morning
that was considered in the morning um
we were still in that morning
was it when they came in was it light
outside
i believe so
did you see anybody coming and going
from the apartment next door to
apartment four
no i didn't
when was the last time you saw any
police officers around 3003 springfield
drive
i'm not sure what you're asking what do
you mean what well last time so that was
a bad question
what time
march 13th about one o'clock in the
morning or so is when this all happened
correct and then you were confined i
think you said to your apartment you
said you never left for some period of
time
but you did say chelsea left to go to
the management office correct
do you remember when she did that
uh like i said before i wasn't actually
looking at the time
um
it was daylight outside so it was
daylight out so you know it was
could have been
10 a.m 11 a.m like i said i'm not 100
sure okay do you remember where there's
still police officers around
the building
yeah i believe there was a few officers
um
yes there was
remember crime scene that yellow tape
up and around um i believe that at one
point i know chelsea seen um i know she
remembers looking because when it
started getting daylight you could
actually see and when she left to go to
the management part uh to get management
at that point you can see into the
apartment and we remember seeing we both
actually seen it
there was a i believe a white blanket
which we knew at that time was a body
there was a white blanket in the hallway
over the over a body okay and you could
see the blood on the very end of the
hallway
okay so
when did you finally leave your
apartment
um i'm not like like i said before
i'm not 100 sure if i ever even actually
left
the property that the red you know if i
stayed on property the rest of that day
or not like i said i don't remember if
we got something to eat later that night
i don't even i don't even remember all i
remember is that morning okay you didn't
you didn't go to work that day correct
no i did not and that was because your
cars were blocked in i assume
yes okay
um
mr heather and you and your
and chelsea have filed a lawsuit against
louisville metropolitan or the city of
louisville
and brett hankerson correct and
a bunch of other police officers
as a result of this
yes i believe that is um yes
yeah and is it correct that you're
you're seeking 12 million and one
dollars in damages
absolutely not we have not
spoken of any numbers
okay you have you ever seen the lawsuit
that was filed on your behalf
[Applause]
oh
ah
so
yes would this be marked as defendants
exhibit number one and i'd like to
approach
mr other cannot this has been marked for
his defendants exhibit number one
do you recognize the caption on that
so that's your name there
yeah that's my name yes
um
can you tell us who that says it's it's
against uh versus louisville jefferson
county metro government
um
here
police louisville metro police
department
and detective brett hankinson
about down through there you don't have
to read all those names but how many
different
people have you sued here
if you can count those
looks like b9
and i'm going to turn here to the
page 36
of this document and ask if you can read
paragraph d
just read the part that's
enter
judgment on behalf of plaintiffs
on plaintiffs
against defendant for reasonable actual
damages
in the amount of
12 million to compensate them for the
violation of their first amendment
fourth amendment eighth amendment 14th
amendment
um
that's good enough
actually it says 12 million one dollars
correct
it does and how about read paragraph h
there
for opponents for punitive damages under
state law in the amount of 12 million
and one dollars
thank you
okay
so you were not aware that this lawsuit
was filed
no i'm fully aware that we have a
lawsuit in place um
but like i said uh we haven't discussed
any numbers between me and my lawyer
and that doesn't have that hasn't
influenced your testimony here today is
that correct
what the
fact that you're trying to get some
money out of this
um
of course we want to be compensated but
like i said me and chelsea
have never even mentioned the amount 12
million dollars it's never even
thank you guys nothing further
anything on
are you asking that be admitted
yes it just be
any objection
all right then it will be so admitted
any questions on redirect
cody your lawyer
name is there jeffrey sexton
did you have anything to do with
putting together this complaint
wow
your lawyer did all this
correct
okay that's all i have thank you
anything else mr matthews
oh your honor
all right you may step down thank you
council would you approach for just a
moment
did please hear that
so
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we are going to
take lunch today i don't want you to
think that we're not uh we're going to
put one more witness on probably only do
part of that witnesses testimony and
then we will break for lunch
all right um miss whaley if you'll call
your next witness
sergeant kyle meaney
mimi
okay
oh
you go ahead and take a seat please
if you'd raise your right hand do you
solemnly swear the testimony you're
about to give will be the truth the
whole truth nothing but the truth so
help you god thank you
if you're comfortable taking your mask
off while you testify you may you're not
required to thank you
state your name please kyle meaney
and um how are you employed i'm employed
with the louisville metro police
department
what is your position i'm currently a
sergeant
and how long have you been with the
department i've been with the department
for eight years
in march 2020
what was your position with louisville
metro march 2020 i was working within
the criminal interdiction division and
a unit called place-based investigations
uh and what was the purpose of that unit
so place-based investigations was
essentially
based upon crime mapping that the crime
information center puts together
which is
basically the intelligence side of our
police department they put that
information together based upon uh calls
for service related to violent crime and
more or less try to identify hot spots
within the city of louisville
now was at that time had your unit been
investigating
a group of individuals
in the drug
trafficking business that's correct
um and was one of those individuals
demarcus glover yes ma'am
and
was
as part of that investigation
were a number of search warrants
obtained
uh for different addresses that's
correct
was one of those addresses
3003 springfield drive yes ma'am
and um
was the
was a search warrant obtained an
affidavit provided in a search warrant
obtained 437 3003 springfield drive
apartment 4. yes ma'am that's correct
and whose apartment was that that was
the apartment of miss brianna taylor
now
i want to
show you what is marked as commonwealth
exhibit 124
ask you to examine that document
is that the affidavit that was
attached to the search warrant
for uh apartment four yes ma'am
and is that does is the affidavit
designated
as
request for a no knock warrant that is
correct
and
now i want to
append you on loss exhibit 125
and after you've identified this
document
i'm sorry
that's the physical search warrant that
is related to the affidavit of the
affidavit that was signed by the judge
judges signatures on that warrant
yes ma'am
um
there been prior to obtaining of this
warrant
surveillance done on the apartment
that's the subject of the warrant that
is correct there had been
and during this process of surveillance
conducted on the apartment
was uh were there photographs obtained
of jamarcus glover
at that building there were that's
correct
127.
i asked you
what is contained in first
exhibit 126.
that is a photo of mr glover walking to
the vehicle that he was associated with
with a
appears to be a box in his hand
and then the second photo is him getting
into the vehicle with that box
and
in front of what building that's in
front of the apartment at springfield
3003.
and you are familiar with demarcus
glover yes ma'am that is him in the
photo that is him in the photo
and he has a box in his hand yes ma'am
and that getting into a vehicle
correct okay uh
we would move to admit exhibits 120
4 125 126 and 127.
no objection all right they'll be so
admitted
now on march 12
2020
was there a briefing done
prior to
the plan to execute this search warrant
that you just described on
apartment 3
or apartment 4
3003 springfield that's correct there
was a briefing down at the cid office
and what's the cid office it's just our
office where
basically we had our you know desks our
everybody's
all the units were there that's more or
less where any office work was completed
that needed to be done
and who led that briefing at the cid
office so it was wes barton who led that
briefing
and i believe
detective goodlett kind of assisted him
with it
and as part of that briefing uh was
there a whiteboard
with the various addresses that were
subject of the search warrants that's
correct
yes ma'am it isn't
and
on that white board
one of the addresses listed 3003
springfield
is there a list of
detectives or officers beneath that
address that had been designated to
serve that search warrant that's correct
there is
and above that address is
are there words written knocking
announced yes ma'am that's correct
and is
how many officers are listed below that
were designated to
execute that search warrant total of
eight
okay
and is one of those officers
red hankerson it is
who are the other officers listed
so it's listed noble's door james king
and cosgrove
now if i might add we had multiple
things other units had multiple things
going on that evening so
those positions were kind of dynamically
changed lieutenant hoover ended up out
there
josh door was not out there
and colin king who's listed on here was
no longer out there as well
and what about sergeant mattingly
he was still at that location
so he was there yes ma'am
and um what about uh
detective campbell detective campbell
was there that's correct
and you said lieutenant hoover
lieutenant hoover
um
detective nobles detective nobles
detective cosgrove and detective
hankinson okay so seven all together yes
ma'am
move to admit exhibit uh 128. objection
it'll be so admitted
now you were not involved
with a serving of that search warrant no
ma'am i was not
um you are the
sergeant
over that
pbi unit correct not every one of those
seven detectives who actually served the
warrant were in the pbi unit as you said
correct
all of the detectives however that
served the warrant were experienced
detectives yes ma'am and it served
multiple warrants yes ma'am
okay
steve uh that's all the questions for
sergeant meanie thank you
all right ladies and gentlemen um we'll
go ahead then and take our lunch break
it's quarter after 12
and if you will come back at quarter
after one
and please remember the separation
admonition have a nice lunch i'll see
you back at 1 15.
all right um
as i said we're going to go ahead and
take a break until 1 15 because you are
still on the witness stand please do not
discuss your testimony with anyone okay
thank you
council could you approach for just a
moment
i just want to talk to you a minute
about exhibits
so
what i would prefer is that
nothing be shown on the screen until
something is actually admitted into
evidence because of it unless you
already have an agreement
that everything's coming in or there's
not going to be any objections if that's
the case that's fine
but if there's anything that's
questionable i don't want it up on the
screen where the jury's looking at it
only to be told yeah you're gonna have
to disregard what you just saw we did
send every single one of these phone
numbers too
as numbered okay i just don't know if
there's any objections to any of them so
there's just
one crayons body right yeah there won't
be any objections okay and then you you
all put the complaint up before we had
that
and and i didn't know if that was
already agreed to or not
yeah so let's let's don't do that until
it's already been
admitted and then we can show it to the
jury understand apologies for that by
the way
okay
nice all right thank you all so
these are the ones that were admitted
you can just
keep them right here or you can put them
down there if you plan to still use them
with other witnesses
all right we're back on the record out
of the hearing of the jury i just want
about the um scene visit did you get a
chance to talk with the apartment
manager yes we did uh
it can be done friday thursday or friday
so i was looking ahead at the weather i
mean it looks like maybe tomorrow
morning um
could possibly be okay
but it's whatever but friday it doesn't
look like there's any chance of rain i'd
rather go on a day when it's not raining
since we're going to be outside are you
wanting them on both sides of the
building
yes
and you're you too correct
okay so i'd rather it and it is supposed
to rain early tomorrow morning um but
just maybe not around
um between 10 and noon
if you're okay waiting till friday then
let's
do that
okay
and then you want to just plan on
sometime friday morning like
you could
coming from
out of state okay
okay
so maybe after lunch go that's fine that
should be fine
so
ladies and gentlemen anything to report
from the lunch break
all right
we will resume with sergeant meaney's
testimony and mr matthews thank you your
honor
sergeant d
testified i believe that you've been
with the lmpd for eight years correct
did you have any law enforcement
experience prior to that no sir okay so
when did you attain the rank of sergeant
yes it was
just
believe that year so
see it emerged in november of that year
i believe it was a couple months prior
i'm gonna ask you to keep your voice up
so everybody can hear you okay
um
a couple months prior to
what
when cid when narcotics and ninth mobile
combined okay what i would like to do
with you is try to give the ladies and
gentlemen the jury some understanding of
the layout of the lmpd certainly um
you've referenced to narcotics and cid
are those two separate units so at one
point they were narcotics was its own
separate unit and ninth mobile which
worked primarily by violent crime was a
separate unit
when they merged and became the criminal
interdiction division
it more or less brought narcotics and
violent crime together okay so cid
stands for criminal interdiction
division correct
and with ncid is my understanding
correct that there are different units
that's correct do you know how many
uh you have major case narcotics you
have interdiction which works parcels
and packages that sort of thing as well
as the highway
at one point the point at which i was
there it was two street squads that
worked narcotics two violent crime
squads
a
uh prescription
pill unit and then pbi
okay and is everybody that is connected
with cid a rank of detective or higher
yes sir that's correct do you know how
many officers are assigned to cid i do
not
it's a 10 or 20 or 40 at one point there
was as many as i believe like 60
detectives
and how about
the
the um
you've got cid
and you see you mentioned different
squads are there same individuals
assigned to each squad
so
as as far as well i mean like you
mentioned interdiction that works on the
highway and careers i guess looks at
packages at the airport correct are
those all the same guys all the time
for the most part yes that's correct and
i mean you can move in between units
when the opportunity presents itself but
that would require a vacancy more or
less to be open right
so you mentioned pbi that stands for
place-based investigations that's
correct was that a relatively new unit
that was created within cid it was were
you placed in charge of that yes sir
when did that happen
so
i think
cid became a thing in november of the
year prior
so november towards the end of november
what year are we talking about
the incident the incident that brings us
here is occurred in march 2020
so it would have been 19 sorry 2019
that's when pbi was formed at the end of
correct
okay
and what was the purpose of pbi
so
place-based investigations more or less
took information that came from the
crime information center
it was based on
reports of violent crime that sort of
thing
more or less
hot spot style policing
so it looked at those areas and then
looked at targeted enforcement in those
areas
and when you say hot spots in those
areas what are we talking about a couple
blocks of
experimental blocks it could be
for us it was
um
broadway from 24th to 28th
and then from broadway north to i
believe magazine if i remember correctly
that same block radius so 24th to 28th
and is it late avenue located within
that block yes sir it is and what
i mean was that
the only investigation pbi was
conducting at the time no so we had
multiple different investigations that
we were working within kind of that
general area
and the concept was that you
discovered a target or something and and
went after try to build a case yeah so
basically discover uh what they called a
microcell a cell that was responsible
for criminal behavior and then you would
work a case towards trying to
more or less take the cell down
and it's key players
and and then move on to something else
correct
um and is that you mentioned jamarcus
glover in your direct testimony is that
where jamarcus glover came into the
picture
and how did he fit in
so i would say that jamarcus was
fairly high up within the traffic
trafficking organization that they had
going on on elliott
and if i understand things correctly the
trafficking organization on elliott was
operating out of three houses correct
correct two of them right next door to
each other and one across the street
correct that's correct
so a decision was made
to target those houses
yes to specifically target the drug
trafficking organization that was
operating out of those locations and and
how did you develop that kind of
information so that information was
developed based on
the initial cic assessment which
provides a hot spot and then
more or less it's going out and
looking at reports from the area
just criminal behavior
the
location itself 2424 elliot was a known
spot that had been a problem previously
for the first division same sort of
thing drug trafficking out of the
location
does your unit
put up pole cameras and send people out
to surveil the place and so on yes sir
and is that done pretty frequently yes
okay and then you mentioned you
identified some photographs that showed
jamarcus glover at 3003 springfield
drive correct
how did that come about so that came
about that was uh detective james and
detective goodlett were
surveilling a location that day i can't
remember if they followed him out there
based on the tracker that was on the
vehicle
or if
they had just ended up out there doing
surveillance and he happened to be there
but those photos were taken by detective
goodwill and detective james that day
well how did
3003 become come on the radar of pbi for
this investigation specifically when he
went in and out of the location and
he you're talking about jamarcus glover
yes sir that's correct and in and out of
the location at what 303 springfield
that's correct okay
what so what what was he doing there if
you know
that we don't know we know that he came
out with a package or that day obviously
he came out with a package um
i know the other instances in which
detective james found we used
databases that are commonly used by law
enforcement and
that address came up underneath mr
glover as a known address
or used address
and when i when you say
3003 as a known address are you
referring specifically to apartment four
yes sir and that was brianna taylor's
apartment
did you develop any information
connecting jamarcus glover and brianna
taylor so i know that we had mrs
taylor's car down on elliot avenue on
pole camera as well
and i know that when
they served a subpoena on mr glover's
bank account
that the address that was listed under
that account was also 3003 springfield
track okay and based on all the
information and intelligence that you
gathered um you decided to get search
warrants correct correct and how many
search warrants were obtained let's see
here
believe a total of five
there would have been three on elliot
one on springfield and one over on
muhammad ali correct correct and those
were all part of the same investigations
correct can you tell the ladies and
gentlemen the jury briefly what the
process is to obtain a search for yeah
so
as you are building your investigation
you identify the location itself that
you're looking to search the reason for
which you're looking to search it
and then you start naming specific
factual pieces of evidence that would
lead you to believe that the items
related to what you're searching for
would be found at that location based
upon the probable cause that you
provided in the affidavit
and you put all that information in
writing and take it to a judge correct
and if the judge is satisfied that it's
a valid affidavit and the information is
legit
arises to the level of probable cause
the judge will sign the search warrant
that's correct
so in this case you
had got five search warrants
what were you specifically looking for
at three zero zero three springfield
drive apartment four we believe that
there was probably gonna be narcotics
and or proceeds from narcotics so
currency at that location
and
okay so when you get one once you get
the search warrant what happens next
so more or less you start the process of
just trying to get gather all the
information and individuals who are
going to assist with serving the
warrants you don't just go out and no
sir go bust into place correct correct
um
i've heard the term matrix can you tell
us what a matrix is yeah so a matrix
more or less you're looking at the
different factors that
would establish a level of risk at a
location and it tries to identify a
certain number and whether it's in a
threshold that
an investigative unit can handle it
versus a swot what type of risk factors
are you looking at
it could be anything from previous
violent criminal history to
um
narcotics activity
um
weapons factors that sort of thing so is
this like a form that somebody fills out
that's correct and you score points for
different things correct
and my understanding is if the point
level gets to a certain level then cid
people couldn't go out and do it by
themselves is that correct
that requires swat to become involved
correct okay but and before a search
warrant is is served
does somebody go out and look at the
location physically and
gather information about the layout of
the place and who might be present that
sort of thing typically yes we try to
make sure that we spend some time
surveilling each location
get an idea of obviously what it looks
like so that we can provide it to the
team that is serving tomorrow
and was that done at 3003 springfield
drive i know photos were taken on the
front door and on the front of the
location
but you don't know about anything around
the back or the rest of the layout of
the building outside of that i do not
know i can't
you know if a matrix was performed i was
prepared for that location there was
and who prepared that detective west
barton
and when was that prepared i was
prepared the
morning
of
the warrant service i believe
if the warrant was served on
right after midnight on march 13th
is it your testimony that the matrix was
was prepared on march the 12th that's
correct and what happens once that's
prepared
so once it's prepared
it more or less is approved and
you begin the process of establishing
who's going to serve the warrant at a
location and kind of come up with a
roster more or less okay well we saw
a photograph
of a white board
that was taken from a white board where
that is in the conference room in the
office uh where cid is located so
the the warrant on springfield was going
to be served by cid correct correct and
that's because the matrix score didn't
get high enough to get swat involved
correct
and the other four search warrants were
supposed to be served by swat correct
correct when swat gets involved what
happens
so we met with them i believe a week
prior to warrant service and just kind
of went over
the specific locations and everything
that we had related to the investigation
and more or less get their feedback on
how they want to proceed and did swat
tell you that trying to do five search
warrants simultaneously is crazy
that we can't do it i know we
specifically talked about
the
the ones that we were going to have them
serve which was the elliott locations in
the ali location
specifically that
those two would be a challenge so we did
adjust that evening
for those two locations as far as what
we were going to do
did the swat people even know that
springfield was still on the radar and
going to be served that night to the
best of my knowledge yes sir
okay
but they were not consulted with
reference to springfield correct i know
the day that we met with them we talked
about multiple different addresses and i
know that detective james ended up
sending them an email with
correspondence as it related to
the locations
when you obtain a search warrant you've
got an option to ask for a no knock
warrant correct can you explain to the
ladies and gentlemen of the jury exactly
what a no knock warrant is yeah so a no
knock warrant is essentially
you're going to the location and rather
than knocking and announcing presence
you have
authority via the warrant with the
exception that is written into the
warrant
that you can force entry upon
making it to the door
and why would you want to know knock
warrant so typically you do that in
instances where you're concerned that
somebody might destroy evidence conceal
stuff uh
if they're violent individuals that sort
of thing
and they no knock warrant was sought and
granted for 3003 springfield that's
correct okay so you've got five warrants
issued um
you're going to go do them sometime
around midnight on march the 13th or
12th going into the 13th
what happens after those warrants are
issued
so
after
after the warrants were issued we
briefed that evening
that's
is my understanding correct that there
were two separate briefings correct one
was at cid at the your conference room
were you president of that one
and then there was a separate briefing
at swat for the other four locations
correct that's correct
and
at the briefing
well at the briefing at cid there the
white board had
rosters for each one of the locations
correct correct so is my understanding
correct that
when swat is involved swat goes in and
makes the entry into the
address you're going to search
um they secure everything and then cid
or whoever's performing the actual
search comes in and does the search
that's correct
okay
on springfield there wasn't going to be
any swat though it's going to be cid
guys just go in and do it correct
so you've got
on the whiteboard
you've got five different addresses with
a list of of police officers or
detectives who are going to go to each
one of those locations correct yes sir
how was that made up
so i know we initially sent out an email
asking for volunteers and then really it
was just kind of plugging in
people into different places making sure
that we had a canine
that was available at each of those
locations was that roster made up that
night or was it
as people volunteered to do it it was
that evening or that night
okay
do you know
brett hankerson i do
during the period that we work together
okay
um
and it's my understanding correct that
he volunteered to participate in the
execution of these search warrants yes
sir he did and and he is a canine
officer correct correct
he has a dog you know his dog's name
and what does franklin do franklin
searches for narcotics and is that all
franklin does
that i don't know i know that franklin
was pretty good at finding currency as
well
um but he's not a dog that goes out you
know attracts people or does crowd
control or anything like that no sir
um
so officer hankinson volunteered and he
is the
the k-9 officer assigned to do
springfield correct yes sir
was he
um
when he volunteered to do springfield do
you know whether was he on duty at that
time or was this off duty
i can't remember if he was on duty or
off duty that i don't know that
okay as the k-9 officer does he have any
other role in the service of the search
warrant
typically
because of the way that the units worked
and they worked
so often with one another
well a lot of the guys that are canine
handlers are former narcotics detectives
so typically they were involved in
warrant service if that's what you're
asking okay to your knowledge was
detective hankerson a former narcotics
officer before he became a k-9 that's my
understanding yes sir
and when you say typically guys work
together
my understanding is that
these different groups that were going
to these different addresses were just
kind of
put together they weren't regular units
that work together all the time is that
correct work together in the sense that
lots of times when we had multiple
things going on it was very common for
units to work and ask for help from one
another
okay well is is a unit
kind of like a team you get to know each
other and you know what each other does
what each one does and you each have a
role correct
um was that the case with these units
that were put up on the whiteboard for
march 12th
yeah i mean i feel like
everybody worked well together and they
were pretty cohesive
okay
at the briefing
who conducted that briefing before
springfield it was detective barton
and was there any discussion about i may
have covered this but was there any
discussion about
how springfield was laid out
i don't recall if there was anything
specific about how it was laid out other
than like i said the photos
of the front of the front
um
and i get another thing that is my
understanding is that
once the briefing is conducted
everybody gets together and goes
somewhere close to the location and you
kind of muster up there correct correct
before that happens
what what is a vo
uh verification officer what does the
verification officer do verification
officer is typically the person who is
already on scene who's conducting
surveillance that can let us know that
if anything changes during the course of
between brief to getting to the location
they can kind of more or less put that
information out on the radio off also
the purpose of the verification officer
is to verify that it is the correct
location
and is the verification officer also
called the eyes that's correct because
he's got his eyes on the location
correct was there a verification officer
assigned to
3003 springfield yes sir and that was
mike campbell correct that's correct do
you know when mike campbell went to
springfield i believe it was like 9 p.m
i don't know if it's it was earlier than
that or later than that but it should
have been about 9. and what is he
supposed to do just sit there and watch
the
the comings and goings at the apartment
more or less get eyes on the location
and update if there's any change at the
location
and where were you when all this was
going on i was at the cid office did you
ever leave cid and go out to elliot or
go to springfield i did not go to
springfield and we had the camera on
elliott so it made it easier to keep
eyes on that location the entire time so
you watched it on
on a video correct
okay
did it to your knowledge did mike
campbell report anything back to
the officers who were going to execute
the search warrant on springfield that
things had changed no sir okay there was
never any
notification given to your knowledge
that a individual
pulled up in a large suv and parked
right in front of this
entranceway object did a hearsay come
approach please
first
okay so sergeant meanie the to your
knowledge the search warrant was
was the officer showed up and were
supposed to go execute the search
warrant right that's correct it's like
you said they've mustered up i just
don't know where at prior to
okay and you didn't have anything to do
with um
with what occurred at springfield is
that right no sir when did you first
learn that something had happened over
the radio
and and how about the
at some point
the no knock warrant issued for
springfield was changed to a knock and
announce warrant tell the jury what a
what a knock and announce warrant is so
knocking announces
you knock on the door you announce your
presence you wait a reasonable amount of
time
before you
can force entry into the location and do
you know who made the decision
to change
springfield from a no knock to a knock
and an ounce so ultimately
the entire time i think
we planned that it was going to be
a
going to announce at that location just
because
the matrix was lower on the risk score
the need for swat was at the other
locations due to the different factors
that we had there including the number
of people
and ultimately
if
what i'm saying is we planned it to be a
knock and announce
why did you get a no knock then
so when we met with swat they initially
asked for all the warrants as it related
to this case to be
no knox
so when detective james went and sought
them
that was included in each of them
okay so sometime prior to going to
springfield
this was changed to at springfield to a
knock and announced correct we briefed
it as a knock and announced that's
correct and when you say we briefed it
who briefed it detective barton okay
um
and the matrix score there on
springfield was low enough that you
could cut swat out of the picture
correct correct
sergeant on the whiteboard picture that
you have
where it describes the address on
springfield
can you read what that says
above it
well just the the numerals in front of
springfield 3003 springfield is that
clear to you or does it look like 3007.
it could be interpreted as a seven i
could see that thank you have no control
redirect
now you stated that the
warrants on elliott were executed by
swat that's correct and you were
president elliot or one of those
and
was demarcus glover located at elliott
on one of the
searches
on elliott that's correct he was and is
that why those were higher risk
so those were higher risk due to the
number of people that were typically
encountered at that location
i know at one point one of the locations
had long guns that were recovered from
their
uh
and yeah just the different factors with
the number of people that you were
usually encountered there
and there was no such indication of any
um urgency or danger on springfield no
ma'am
and was there any knowledge that any
that an another male was living on that
a male was living at department for
springfield my knowledge no ma'am
thank you
anything else may i ask just one word
judge sure
sergeant do you know if the search on
springfield was ever actually served by
cid the apartment was ever searched by
cid so no we never actually got out
there to search the apartment
and franklin never came out of his car
and went in at any time correct
thank you my knowledge
anything else of this witness
you may step down thank you
all right your next witness
mike nobles
so
work
dude
that's
you should take a seat please
and if you'll raise your right hand
do you sell this where the testimony
you're about to give will be the truth
the whole truth nothing but the truth so
help you god
thank you
you may leave my mans going wrong you
can take it off while you're testifying
thank you judge
you okay
all right
can you go ahead and tell the jury your
name please
mike nobles
and where do you currently work
the local metro police department's
criminal interdiction unit how long have
you been with lmpd
15 years 15 years
then you just described the unit you're
assigned to how long have you been with
that unit
since 2017
and just so that we kind of get to know
you a little bit better where are you
originally from
are you from louisville somewhere else
outside louisville just outside
louisville
and you've described yourself as
obviously being a police officer for
quite some time what training did you
have or received before becoming a
police officer
well i joined the i joined the police
department 2006 i went to the
their academy class and then in the 15
years that i've been a police officer
i've
attended several training
for different positions on the
department
all right
and
i'm going to go forward and go to
march 12th or the early morning hours
march 13th of 2020. were you working as
a police officer then
yes and what unit were you assigned to
the same unit
yeah i'm i'm assigned to the airport
parcel interdiction unit okay and within
that unit what do you do on a daily
basis
i interdict
packages from different parcel carriers
located here
in louisville
and on the early morning hours of march
13th of 2020 what was your assigned role
or what were you doing on that assigned
day
well the evening of march 12th
well during the day at marshfield i was
contacted to see if
i was available for a search warrant
that night that evening how were you
contacted by my sergeant okay who would
that be sergeant john mandela okay
now when you get contacted is this a
voluntary thing
it absolutely was i was out of town when
he called me
okay
and so he received the email what'd you
do next
it was a phone call phone call
and i i agreed and told him yes i would
it wasn't till that evening
okay
so going forward that evening when did
you first meet up or get uh get to that
assignment
we met at the uh we met at the office at
7th and normsby
later on in the evening
nine or ten o'clock i believe is when
the
meeting was to go over the warrants okay
what office was that
that's our cid's office yeah
okay
who all was there when you got the cid
there was
a lot of detectives sergeants
okay particularly when you get there
who's going to give the briefing that
night
well i know that the warrant was for the
the pbei pbl units okay
whoever was going to be in charge of
that
okay one of the detectives on that unit
okay now when you attend this briefing
you're not giving it you're just
receiving is that correct
yeah okay
do you remember the details of that
briefing or what you were briefed on
that evening before you left
uh we were i was assigned to the
springfield address
do you know approximately what time you
left that briefing
it was after 10 pm
do you remember anything about the type
of uh
type of briefing that you received or
the type of warrant that you would be
performing that night
yeah it was a knocking announce warrant
we were there just to look for mail
matter
anything linking
the main suspect okay do you remember
what time you left
it was after
the meeting was 10 i'm not sure what
time we left okay where did you go first
after the meeting
we went and met at the church at st
andrews church room okay and is that in
close proximity to uh 3003 springfield
drive yes okay
what why is it that you meet there prior
to going to the address on the warrant
because we were told we're not going to
do we're not going to execute that
warrant until the main suspect was in
custody
okay
do you remember who the main suspect was
at that time
yeah jamarcus glover
okay
now when you get to
uh the church parking lot as you
described do you remember who was there
at the
at the meeting point
yeah they're all the detectives that
were on on my team okay do you remember
who was on the team with you if you
could name them
yeah
there was sergeant mattingly
there's brett
tony james
miles cosgrove
mike campbell
sean hoover
so you all meet there is there anyone
else staging there with you bms okay is
that typical
why and why is that
we always if you're going to do a
warrant you want to have ems close by in
case something does happen okay
so you all stage do you remember what
you do next
we waited for the phone call we waited
for the call to uh
give it a go to go
to springfield okay do you remember if
there were any assignments given that
night amongst your team that you just
mentioned
particular roles unit
yeah what were you assigned to my role
was uh
the ram
has to be the rim of the door okay and
just so that the jury knows what's the
approximate weight of a ram
50-60 pounds okay
are you able to be armed while you have
that ram no okay
what position would you be within the
team as a ram
would you be front back that'd be the
very front okay
do you remember if anybody else had
assigned roles that evening within
within that group
sergeant battling was the point
mike campbell was the vo verification
officer the rest of the guys lined up
behind us
okay
and
you met up
you got your assigned roles what did you
do next
sergeant manly received the phone call
that
the warrants were being executed on uh
okay uh once those
once those were executed we were given
the go to go ahead to
do
springfield
remember anything about getting to
springfield the arrival can you describe
that for us
yeah we we drove
each of us drove our vehicles into the
parking lot
uh when we arrived we parked short of
the apartment there was a there was a
white suv that was parked in the middle
of the parking lot that then wasn't a
police officer we didn't know who's it
was
once we parked there
we got out and we lined up
okay
now
you said you didn't recognize one of the
vehicles
was that in your briefing or was that
new to you it was new to us did that
change your demeanor in any way or did
what did you do
well we still have we still have the
apartment that we had to
approach
nobody was in the vehicle but yeah it
was it was new to us it was something
new that wasn't there
in prior drive-throughs okay
so what do you do next
we were lined up on the sidewalk and we
walked
into the uh
little hallway area first floor
bottom floor
approached the door
okay
your honor may i approach the witness
you may
i'm going to show you what has been
marked as exhibits 19
5 and had to take a look at these
what are those pictures depicting right
there
that's the
entrance
entrance way to uh springfield and that
the door is
the target door okay and what's the
other uh photo is that the door
yes are those a fair and accurate
representation of the night when you or
the night uh of the apartment door
location when you arrived on that search
warrant 3003 springfield drive yes your
honor this time i would move to admit
those two into evidence as 19 and 5.
any objection no your arm they'll be so
admitted at this time i'm going to
display them for the jury on the screen
that's fine
hey detective nobles i'm going to have
i'm going to give you a laser pointer
have you point out
in the photo that i'm going to show you
in a second where you were when you
actually arrived
and walked to the scene
that you just described where are you in
this picture
um
underneath the steps right next to the
door
okay and you're first in line you said
once we get to the door
once we get to the door i'm on the right
side of the door sergeant manali is on
the left side of the door
miles was
in between us
more behind sergeant mattely okay you
said miles is that detective cosgrove
yes where is everyone else assigned or
where are they lined up
they're stacked up behind miles up into
this corner and then coming back around
okay do you know where each position of
the individuals were
okay
who was up near the door right in your
area
dr mattingly and um
detective castro okay could you see
above you what was your viewpoint
i knew that there was a second floor
deck the stairs going up okay
when you approach this area did you
notice anything about the surrounding
apartments
no okay what was the lighting at that
time
no
[Music]
porch light it wasn't well lit but it
was lit was it light dark was like
light bright bright but it was light
enough to see everything okay
and was this at midnight so in terms of
the sky was it dark yes okay
could you see into that apartment right
there the sliding glass window in the
picture
no
okay
could you see
into the door that you are now in front
of
it's closed okay
when you're standing there do you ever
hear any type of commotion noise or are
you just focused on the door what's
going on
uh when we first approach the door we do
knock on the door
and a gentleman from upstairs comes out
and starts to yell at us telling us to
leave and
you know he didn't have very nice words
to say
now when you say somebody above could
you see them i could hear them you could
hear them okay
was this after or before you knocked
exactly how many times do you think you
knocked
four or five i mean it was a hard knock
four or five okay
did you all announce
yes what did you say when you announced
please
okay do you know how many times you
announced your presence at this address
i don't it's habit for when you approach
a door
is when you're knocking you're yelling
police
okay
at what point does the person come out
that you just described when you were
knocking
almost immediately after the first set
of knocks okay
did this cause a change to your plan at
all absolutely what why go ahead and
explain that
it took detective hankinson and
lieutenant hoover's
concentration off of the door
and they started to deal with this
gentleman to help try to coerce him back
inside
we were still standing by the door
sergeant mattel and i continued to knock
on that door
while they were trying the courses man
to go back in
was detective hankinson speaking with
the gentleman upstairs
i can hear him talking to him yeah okay
at some point does anyone
in your team
besides detective hankinson engage with
the uh
neighbor upstairs lieutenant hoover okay
what happens next after that engagement
while they're still in engagement uh
sergeant manley and i are still knocking
on the door
the gentleman finally goes inside
while we're knocking on the door i can
hear somebody inside uh i know that
sergeant man told me to go ahead and hit
it i said i hear somebody so we did
another set of knocks
there was no answer so i was given to go
to go ahead and hit door okay now i'm
going to show you what we just mentioned
as
this picture right here which is the
door
where are you when you just described
that movement of getting ready to knock
and now getting ready to ram where are
you right here okay and where is where's
everyone else in that uh doorway so the
natalie's right here okay and i know
that miles is right here behind me
okay i don't know what happened
okay i don't know what order everybody
else was in now
when you start to do the ram
how are you taught to do a ramp what
point of contact are you trying to reach
does that make sense what point of
contact are you trying to bring the ram
to the door
on the hinge side my point of contact is
to try to open that door as fast as
possible
is it on the door knob side or the hinge
side door knob side and on this door
where is the door knob side
right side
okay how many times do you estimate you
rammed that door three times three times
and on the third time what happened
it flew open
it flew open in the direction that the
door is currently positioned
yes
okay
now
this next part i know may not be easy
you ram the door it opens
what happened next
as soon as it opened
sergeant manly took
a half a step inside i noticed i saw
the only thing i saw disappear into that
apartment from my view was his elbowing
his elbow in holding the gun
he started yelling no no no took a shot
to the groin
and he stepped back
and he just started to fire
where are you when this is happening
right here by the door i didn't even
have time to drop the ram
okay
what happens next
i drop the ram
uh detective or i'm sorry sergeant
mountain is standing on this rug area in
the doorway shooting
he's in pain he goes down
right in here
miles
cosgrove steps over top of him
while he's still in this fatal funnel
and starts shooting while john gets out
of the way
john knows he's shot
you just mentioned the term fatal funnel
what does that mean
it's when you're when
a fatal funnel is when you're standing
in a light where if you're in a dark
area and somebody's standing in a
doorway with light behind them you can
see them they can't see you
could you ever see in that door no
was it black star
you said that you were obviously with
the ram and you hadn't even gotten out
of the way
what happens next for you
well with all the i don't i don't know
how many shots uh i i didn't count how
many shots uh sergeant mattel had taken
no miles but it sounded
in that in that area the echo was
extremely loud
knowing that john was shot from inside
the apartment i didn't know what was
inside and if there was going to be any
bullets flying through
i just
ducked down and tried to
come back toward the back of the
staircase
until i looked back and saw john i tried
to get him out of the way because he was
down right there in the middle of the
door
were you armed when any of this was
going on no
i was on i was i had a pistol but i was
not it wasn't out of holster did you
ever draw your pistol at any point no
and why is that
it happened so fast
okay
at any time did you identify any target
i never saw anybody
i never looked inside the apartment okay
what happens next in terms of what you i
think you described as you were trying
to help john what what do you do there
once everybody cleared out john stood up
we grabbed him lieutenant hoover grabbed
him
i grabbed his other side and we
ran out
of that area
and uh
we took cover behind that white suv that
was parked in front of the apartment
okay
the time that you just described in that
doorway was detective henkeson ever in
the doorway with you
i don't recall
you pull
detect it mattingly from that area what
do you all do next
taking behind the
white suv
we lay them down beside the driver's
side
the front driver
tire
because we we still think that there's a
shooter inside
uh
we tear
we've ripped uh manila's pants at the
leg
lieutenant hoover removes his belt
and we use that as a tourniquet
so you
we tended to john's wounds tended to his
wounds at some point are you able to
evacuate detective mattingly from that
area
we picked him up put him on the trunk of
a vehicle and i drove it down to the
bottom of the hill
where lieutenant hoover picked him up
putting in angles
okay
do you remember ever seeing detective
hankinson render aid to detective
mattingly
i just saw tony james sean hoover and
john mannelly okay
what do you do next after you've
rendered aid and loaded him up
i
told john i found him to the hospital
well he asked me to follow him to the
hospital so once he was in wagon
i ran back to my truck and made sure
that i was right behind the
bms okay
you arrived at the hospital
how long were you there
an hour
okay where did you go next
while i was at the hospital
piu public integrity
sergeant told me to
head on to the office yeah and where did
you go
piu office on taylor boulevard okay
why do you all go to piu after an
incident
that's where they do it
they do a debrief uh you have to speak
with uh
before we meet the lawyer and then
you have to give a statement
okay
is that
protocol
yes okay
unless told otherwise that they tell you
to come back
at any point when you were still on the
scene that night did you ever see
detective hankinson take a shot
in terms of shooting his own weapon i
did not
never at the door
i did not know that
brett shot
all right thank you very much i
appreciate it and i know that was hard
so thank you nothing further you're on
cross-examination
thank you your honor
back on
march 13th where you detective or
sergeant detective are you sergeant now
no sir but still detect okay
um i wasn't sure if i've heard the
beginning here um you've been with lmpd
for 15 years correct
going on 15 yes and how long have you
been with cid
up
2017
i want to say in summer 2017. is that
when cid was first formed no it was
metro narcotics at the time
okay
and uh
while we were in metro narcotics about a
year and a half in they switched it to
criminal interdiction unit have you
known brett
for
part a great part of your career
known him since dad came on okay and
would you classify yourselves as friends
absolutely
good
um
now you your role with cid is i
understand cid there's different little
units correct yes sir and you're with
the uh parcel airport parcel
interdiction unit yes does that mean you
spend all your time at at the airport or
how does that work
eighty percent of my time at uh all the
different
parcel
places in
louisville
post office fedex ups
and what do you do
you look for suspect parcels
are there a lot of those that come
through here
um
okay you indicated that on march 12th
you were on vacation somewhere correct
march 12th i was on my way back from
washington d.c
and you received a call from john
mattingly asking you if you wanted to
work over be part of this search team
yes sir
you agreed to do it correct yes sir you
were given a time to report to the cid
office yes sir
you didn't do anything before that
correct
yes i did what did you do before that uh
6 p.m i had a meeting
at 6 00 pm i had a meeting at ups ground
with sergeant manly and the other
detective that i work with
did that have anything to do with this
nothing to do with this search warrant i
had i had other duties to do when i got
back in town okay
um
what time did you report to cid
to do this search warrant detail
it was
between nine and ten it was
that night
you indicated there were quite a few
detectives there
oh yeah yes sir
and
where when you got there did you know
you were assigned to the uh 3003
springfield location or how did that
come about
once we went into the meeting room and i
looked at the board
i saw the name was felt wrong on that
board but i figured that was supposed to
be me anyway so
and somebody so somebody made that
assignment they didn't ask you if that's
where you wanted to go they just
made that assignment okay
um
you indicated that uh
well at the briefing what what it was
there any what was the description about
3003 springfield that you were
provided or were given any information
about that location
other than a female and a possible
younger sibling
i was just there because that's where
demarcus glover usually laid his head
numerous times were you giving any
details about the physical layout
no
okay
um
and
were you away
did you know originally that it was a no
knock warrant that you were supposed to
execute
no i i just figured it was a knocking
announce which
i mean did anybody tell you that or did
you just see it written on board
now
you don't have to announce you don't
it's a no knock it's supposed to be an
element of surprise you're not gonna
announce yourself if nobody answers
okay
so you all
i think you said you met at the church
lot on st andrews yes
and then everybody drove what
individually up to to the springfield
apartment yes sir after you received
word from over on elliot that it was
time to go correct
yes uh sergeant matlin was the point of
contact so he's the one that made the
call and told us to
mount up and go okay and when you got up
to springfield
how did that work everybody just parked
find a place to park and park we just we
we were all lined up coming to the
parking lot and we stopped shy of the
apartment all lined up and we got out
and
made our way onto the sidewalk and lined
up yeah if i understand correctly mike
campbell was already there as the eyes
correct
he was the vo yes and
did he report anything to you before you
got there about anything unusual or any
changes
he would have reported to john and
john didn't say anything okay
you mentioned i thought if i heard you
say something about uh
you you took a look at the building
through on a prior drive through
i didn't
john manley did
john mattingly did he did a
drive-through while we were at the
parking lot
it just by himself
yeah when we were fighting i think he
did the draft there just to see that
layout
and was it your understanding that mike
campbell was up there at that time
yes okay
um
so you all get up there and you see the
big white suv parked right in front of
where you want to go in is that right
yes sir did that alter the plans at all
or cause anybody any concern to your
knowledge
it raised concern but it didn't alter
the plans we didn't know if that was if
the car was involved
in that apartment or not and you
testified it was unoccupied correct
correct so was there was there anybody
around
as you all approached the apartment
somebody was around okay
um
and then you testified at some point
somebody came out from an upstairs
apartment correct correct
when was that in the in the whole
sequence
he heard us knocking and announcing on
that door and he came outside to tell us
to leave that girl alone
okay you just indicated that
the difference between a no knock and a
knock in an ounce is 15 seconds
did you
was that what you waited before you used
the ram or was it at least two i would
say two or three minutes
two or three minutes on the initial
first initial knock
okay and why was that
because when we first started knocking
the gentleman upstairs came out
and it took
it took detective hank and sending
lieutenant hoover's eyes off of what we
were doing and they were focusing on
getting him back in the apartment okay
was it important that their eyes be
focused on what you were doing
yes
and was it important that he be
gotten away from the scene and back into
an apartment or out of the way we would
rather be inside and not be outside in
case something happens did that take a
bit of time to accomplish that is that
why you waited two to three minutes yes
okay
um
and then i think i heard you say that
your location was right under the steps
correct yes sir could you see the fellow
upstairs that they were having the
conversation with no sir
and you're you were the ram man right
sir so
you you're
you're not standing right in front of
the door is that correct no i'm just
upset
and you are you knocking also or as you
say who who always knocking
sergeant madeline myself
do you know what's at that time he was
at the time that they were talking to
the gentleman
here behind me that's all
okay would that be when he said
would he been back there in that
vestibule or breezeway area
i would say so i'm sorry i didn't take
my eyes off that door
you heard some noise in the apartment i
did heard somebody say who is it
which we knocked again
and yelled police again
and did you receive a response we did
not okay and that's when sergeant
mattingly gave the order to hit the door
correct yes sir i believe you testified
it just depends on
how good the wood is you remember brett
hankerson making some comment about your
door opening skills what did he say it
was just something
to hurry up get that door open
he was there watching you hit the door i
assume correct yes okay
and you hit the door
do you know precisely where
in
to the door but as soon as
that door flung open up i just hugged
the wall and i turned my back to the
wall and why did you do that
i don't
i don't have a gun or anything i'm just
out in the middle just out there
wide open correct
it's a dangerous position okay so you
you spun out of the way and what and
immediately there was gunfire
yeah uh the door flies opening up
sergeant manly saying please please
search warren please search warren as
soon as i
see
his forearms disappear into the
got a apartment down
you